&gt;&gt; Let's go back to the equation that we started this whole problem off with, 3
over x minus 1 over 5x equals 7. So we already solved the problem one way and
that was to combine our 2 fractions into 1 and then proceed. However there is
another method, and it's always good to explore a little bit more. The second
thing that we could start off by doing, would be to Get rid of our fractions
right off the bat. And we know that the way we get rid of fractions is to
multiply fractions by numbers. So, let's think about what number we could use.
Since x of the denominator of the first fraction on the left hand side, let's
start off trying with that. What equation do we have if we take the single step
of multiplying both sides of this equation by x? Fill in the left side that
we'll be left with here, and the right side that we'll be left with here. You
can of course, combine like terms and simplify on either side of the equation if
you want to. I just don't want you to do anything else that modifies both sides
of the equation.